the Marine Admirals are some of the
strongest characters in all of One Piece
with the likes of Garth akinu or sengoku
being more than capable of fighting even
yonko level Pirates which actually makes
you wonder what would happen if the
Admirals had actually become Pirates
instead of Marines and we're starting
this video at Lightspeed with Admiral
kizaru or as he's known in this timeline
captain barcelino now in case you didn't
know every admiral has a code name that
translates in Japanese to a color and an
animal so kizaru meaning yellow monkey
however since borsolino never became a
Marine in this timeline he never gets
this code name so what would this guy be
like if not for the Marines let's take a
look at his inspiration is he every
single Admiral is based on a famous
Japanese actor in this case vorcelino is
based on kuniitanaka an actor well known
for playing thugs Mobsters or even
Yakuza members and in addition his name
Borsalino actually comes from a French
movie called Borsalino which is also
about Mobsters in fact just look at this
old flashback version of borcelino and
it's even more clear to tell that this
guy was clearly modeled after a gangster
and so unlike other Admirals he doesn't
go on and on about Justice it seems more
like he's just an enforcer for the most
powerful gang around which is the world
government well let's say that baby
barcelino didn't want to be a square
working for the man where would he then
go instead well it seems like an
organized crime family would be the
perfect place for him which would put
him right at home on a crew-like Capone
Pages unfortunately though the timeline
doesn't really work for that since beige
only set sail as a pirate a few years
ago in the story but we do of course
have another wonderful Contender for a
mafia which is the donkey shot family
that's right in this timeline a young
borcelino looking for a job where he
gets free reign to beat people up what
cross paths with none other than the
doflamingo family treble and the other
Executives would make him an offer that
he couldn't refuse in just the same way
that the world government gives kizeru
free reign to deal with pirates though
Flamingo status as a Celestial Dragon
also grants his crew a certain degree of
immunity from consequences so for the
sake of argument we'll just say that
somewhere along the way Borsalino will
still get his light like devil fruit
after all as underworld Brokers the
doflamingo family is pretty good at
procurring anything that they want
including strong devil fruits and we can
even say that Pika helps him get the
pika pika know me I don't know why I did
that joke anyways at this rate this kind
of raises one big concern how can
borcelino be a subordinate on dolphy's
crew if let's be real he is much
stronger than doflamingo and to be fair
it is kind of out of the ordinary for a
crewmate to be stronger than their
Captain but does borsolino really strike
you as the ambitious Captain type I mean
just remember he was more than happy to
just sit back and relax while kaino and
aokiji fought over the fleet afro
position in other words as long as he
has the power to do whatever he wants
borcelino seems very much happy to play
the second fiddle to someone else and
not have to carry all those burdensome
responsibilities that come with being
the top dog now of course doflamingo
having a Powerhouse like Borsalino
working with him would totally alter the
landscape of one piece I mean the early
beginnings of the trajectory look pretty
much the same they would capture dress
Rosa with ease and dolphy would be named
one of the seven Warlords still however
doflamingo wouldn't be satisfied
stopping there and working as an arms
dealer for the other yonko because with
the additional power afforded by
Borsalino he would expand his Empire and
actually become a yonko with territory
on par with big moms tauntlands and I'd
even go so far as to theorize that with
doflamingo being pushed against strong
opponents and having stronger
subordinates he himself might even grow
much stronger compared to where we see
him in the story in other words once
draw heads would later arrive onto US
Rosa dolfi would have both borsolino and
fujitora on his side allowing him to
decimate the straw hat Alliance
borcelino would even take out Sanji with
a light speed kick and so for his status
as a yonko commander and probably the
strongest at that barcelino would earn
at least a bounty of 1 billion berries
however this Berry is nothing compared
to the ones we'll see later in the story
now fujitora the purple tiger on the
other hand or isho as he's known in the
timeline is a very mysterious guy I mean
he's clearly a Samurai and where are
samurai from well wano as far as we know
and who did we not hear from at all
during the wild Arc that is right isho
now for the sake of argument here with
no other leads to go on we're just gonna
assume for the moment that issue is
actually from wano and it just hasn't
been revealed quite yet after seeing all
the atrocities committed by Orochi and
kaido in his homeland he cut out his own
eyes and blind find it himself he then
probably left wano to wonder the world
very much like the character that he's
based on zatoichi the blind Samurai
who's portrayed by sintarukatsu however
in this timeline he first wanders
directionless but after finding and
eating the gravity Foods ishin believes
that he has gained enough power to take
his country back in other words he vows
to take revenge for his homeland and set
sail as a pirate the first step is to
find fellow allies who are similarly
invested in the fight for wano and it
just so happens that several survivors
from wano were hiding out creating a new
life for themselves in the East blue and
so inshimotsuki Village most of the
citizens don't have a lot of confidence
in their ability to do anything against
kaido but isho does rally a few people
including a tenacious young swordsman
with his eyes set on becoming the
world's strongest swordsman that's right
in this timeline ishel's first mate is
none other than a young Zorro the great
nephew of one of his shows former
comrades she molds keoshimaru and since
the fujitora that we know has a real
love for gambling we think it wouldn't
be past him winning some more powerful
crewmates through the pirate gambling
game known as The Daily backfight so
maybe after learning about the game from
the foxy Pirates and easily defeating
them they use this game to recruit more
strong allies to advance on the forces
of wanu and once they finally Sail on
wano kaido's forces would see a fleet of
ships approaching bearing an ominous
Jolly Roger a skull crushing down to
earth like a meteor now I think the
forces of the Beast Pirates would be
completely caught off guard as giant
meteors crash down upon onigashima in
other words the Beast Pirates would now
be under siege by isho captain of the
meteor Pirates and using this as their
opportunity to attack the red scabbards
would also come out of their hiding to
serve as allies in the sudden war on
kaido and orochi's forces then after a
Hartford battle a meteor would Plunge
kaido Into the Depths beneath walnuts
burn in the magma Mount Fuji and for
defeating a yonko kisho could then earn
a bouncy of 3 billion and be named one
of the four Empress which honestly we
don't know if fujitora would be actually
strong enough to take on someone like
Heidel but now we need to really stretch
our imaginations and ask the question
what if kuzan was a pirate oh wait oh
he's already oh he's already a pirate
well as the 10th Titanic captain of the
Blackbeard Pirates Admiral aokiji or
blue pheasant now going by his real name
kuzan is about as pirate as you can get
already however while we're using our
imagination let's spread a bit of an
alternate timeline for him as well now
in our timeline aokiji doesn't leave the
Marines after his fight with a kaino and
instead he leaves far earlier when he
first starts doubting whether the
Marines are truly representing Justice
in other words after the O'Hara incident
and after seeing the innocent civilians
of O'Hara murdered by akinu he decides
to leave the Marines in order to seek
the truth about what exactly the world
government has been covering up here and
that actually makes sense because you
see kuzan is actually based on an actor
named yusaku matsuda whose most famous
role is playing a detective in a series
called detective story perfectly fitting
for someone who would want to uncover
the truth of the world and so here he
rescues his old camera Saul from his ice
time capsule and together they set sail
hiding a young Nico Robin the sole
survivor of Ohara using the resources of
elbaf Saul still manages to rescue the
saved books from Ohara and hides all of
them away and kuzan and Robin keep
exploring the world in secret collecting
poniglyphs in order to uncover the true
history and then as Robin grows up she
becomes officially recognized as kuzan's
first mate then I could absolutely see
kuzan being approached by monkey the
dragon leader of the revolutionaries but
declines to join forces with them theirs
is a journey to seek knowledge not to
wage war against the world government
however their factions are friendly
towards one another I think as they
probably are right now however there's
actually another up-and-coming pirate
with the goal of learning the meaning of
the D initial and what happened during
the white Century joining together with
kuzan's crew as the ship's doctor is
Trafalgar law and so due to their low
profile and stealthy operations trying
to avoid conflict when possible the
permafrost Pirates are able to gather
the pony glyphs without bringing too
much attention to themselves and I
picked a crew name because it comes from
a combination of kuzan's ice abilities
along with permafrost association with
finding well-preserved fossils of
extinct animals by threading for an
archaeologist like Robin and all of the
crew I think I mean just imagine a crew
were robins and lost strategically
Brilliant Minds can enact plans without
Luffy there to completely ruin them
pretty much instantaneously and with the
muscle that kuzan can provide where it's
needed if they do get in a fight in
other words I would argue that this crew
might very well have a good shot at
being able to obtain the one piece but
later on in this video they'll have some
serious competition for it for kuzan's
Jolly Roger I could see being a
shivering skull encased in ice and for
threatening to reveal the true history I
think kuzan earns a bounty of 5 billion
berries but next up we have a kind of
honorable mention and it is kuzan's old
Mentor Monkey D GARP now he is not an
admiral but only because he does keep
turning down the position and so Garb
AKA Luffy's Grandpa aka the hero of the
Marines really just makes sense as a
pirate I mean just look at this picture
of him as a child I mean does this
little wild boy riding a tiger with a
treasure really feel like a marine or
does this look like a pirate to you now
we're actually not 100 sure what garp's
initial motivations for joining the
Marines actually were in the first place
but we do know why he refuses to become
an admiral that's because ever since the
god Valley incident he's harbored a real
hatred for the Celestial Dragon so in
our new timeline we'll take it one step
further whatever happened at got valley
during the battle against rocks
alongside Roger didn't just convince
GARP to hate the the celestial dragons
it convinced him to turn his back on the
Marines entirely and so after God Valley
we know Roger was inspired to seek out
the pony glyphs uncover the true history
and find love tale but this time he has
his new best bro traveling ride
alongside him as a member of his crew
and after Roger's death unfortunately I
think he wasn't in the position to save
Ace and in addition his rebellious
grandson Luffy might even be inclined to
become a Marine in this timeline since
things are so flipped around however
like many of the Roger Pirates Garb
would probably take up residence in a
key point of the grand line looking for
and aiding the potential next Joy Boy
Billy it's probably not a coincidence
that crocus lived at the very start of
the grand line Rayleigh at the halfway
point and both of them helping Luffy on
his journey and so I like to think that
GARP would then settle down on Roadstar
Island which is the last official island
of the grand line waiting there for
joyboy to arrive and for his betrayal of
the world government and aiding the
pirate king GARP would probably earn a
bounty of at least 5 billion berries as
well and actually while we're at it what
about another person from Roger's era
because before he was Fleet Admiral
sengoku must logically have held the
position of Admiral as well which makes
us ask what if sengoku was a pirate now
this one is the absolute wildest in the
lineup I think because out of every
character who's held a position of
Admiral xengoku is by far the least
piratey of all of them however there are
a few instances where we do see
sengoku's faith in the Marine
organization being tested one of these
moments is the death of Rosie Nancy
others include the cover-up of the imple
down escape and even the entirety of the
shichibukai system and so could these be
enough to make sengoku the Quint
essential honorable Marine quid though
oh honestly probably not but he could
pretend to be a pirate as a sword member
just like X-ray and so fooling exactly
no one singaku would set out as the
captain of the actually a pirate crew
and he would frequent place as popular
with other pirates in order to gather
secret Intel for the Marines but should
he actually dared to call him on his
very obvious Bluff be ready to face down
against the one-eyed Buddha his ancient
zoan form but now wearing his eye patch
like of course a real pirate woods but
to help make his cover even better the
Marines have given him a very convincing
bouncy of 10 000 berries which is of
course absolutely nothing compared to
the last Admiral on our list but first
back to the current Admirals though
because we have the latest Admiral that
we've met in the series green Bowl real
name aramaki based on a character from
the samurai film Ronan guy named aramaki
obvious and really he just seems to use
his new position as an admiral to run
absolutely crazy with his powers he's a
divotee of Fleet Admiral Akainu and is
more than happy to use violence to try
to subjugate wano under the authority of
the world government answer really head
aramaki just been a pirate I could
definitely see him being a pirate like
useless kid for example he really seems
to enjoy harming the weak or the
innocent just because he can and due to
his survival of the fittest mentality he
might actually get along really well
with the Beast Pirates but we have a
feeling that without a Zone fruit kaido
just won't let you into the crew no
matter how strong you are really gotta
make sure to keep that theme consistent
instead in order to reign aramaki in the
government would probably give him a
position as a warlord so much in the way
that he was conscripted into the Marines
as an admiral this way the government
would still get to utilize his powers
while giving him some free reign to
commit the acts of violence that he does
really seem to enjoy what a nice person
and if you're sailing at Sea and happen
to see a forest coming towards you you
should probably turn around it might
just be the Wildwood Pirates you can
tell that for certain by the Jolly Roger
a skull overgrown with foliage and Ivy
and their Captain the forest man aramaki
who has a frozen 1 billion very bouncy
that he got before becoming a warlord
but of course aramaki might actually fit
in better as the subordinate of our next
Marine turned Pirates zakazuki as you
know Akainu the current Fleet Admiral is
an adherent to Absolute Justice he does
hate pirate with every fiber of his
being and wants nothing more than to
live in a world without them so really
what could ever convince him out of all
people to become a pirate well based on
sakazuki's childhood picture here it
seems like he actually had a very
difficult and violent past and so my
guess is that his hatred of pirates is
deeply rooted in his childhood where he
probably suffered greatly at the hands
of pirates at some point but what would
have happened if he had actually fallen
into the cycle of violence and crime
instead of trying to rise above it after
all his likeness bunta sugawara is known
for playing raw masculine and violent
characters and so what if sakazuki
actually decided to become a pirate to
end all other pirates in other words
many Pirates do seek the one piece for
weld fame or power but not sakazuki he
wants to find the one piece with the
singular aim of destroying it because
that way it will never Inspire another
pirate to ever set sail again and
honestly he'd have a pretty good shot at
doing it as well because there is
actually a question Corner quote from
Oda that once said that if a kainu was
the protagonist of the series he'd find
the one piece in one year no need for a
two-year time skip for this guy but
actually this is actually a
misconception based on a slight
mistranslation of that quote what Oda
actually said is that with a protagonist
as strong as a kainu he'd finish riding
one piece in a year but isn't that even
crazier I mean how much time actually
passes throughout a year of publication
in the actual one-piece story not that
much less than a year I would say for
sure just for reference the rate on
onigashima which was actually less than
a knight was published over the span of
two real life years so what sakazuki
just sailed straight up to all the
Emperors claim their Road Pony glyphs
and had to laugh tail all in like one
night I mean honestly maybe so
especially if he manages to recruit
similarly ruthless crewmates because
honestly I would absolutely see people
like shitiu Luchi and aramaki joining a
kainu people who hide their bloodlust
behind the banner of Justice because
they would fit right in with his crew
the crew which of course would be named
the Bonsai Pirates named for sakazuki's
favorite hobby sakazuki would then set
sail for love tail very quickly his ship
flying a Jolly Roger bursting from the
top like a volcanic eruption similar to
how any pirate inhabited Islands they
pass through would look once he was done
with them and then for spreading
violence Carnage and fear throughout the
entire one piece world sakazuki would be
named a yonko but he would have no
interest in the title whatsoever or
holding any territory his goal find the
one piece and destroy the one piece I
think as a result he would be fated once
again to face down kuzan but this time
not at Punk Hazard but at laugh tail one
of them fighting to uncover the true
history the other one fighting to
destroy it forever and we do all know
how this fight would probably turn out
sakazuki would prove to be victorious
earning a 10 billion very Bounty and the
title of the last pirate king burning
every Last Remnant of joyboy's treasure
Akino really is an absolute monster no
wonder that Luffy couldn't do anything
to stop him at marineford but I do
wonder if things might have been
different if Luffy had already had all
his hockey and gear 5 Powers at
marineford which lucky for you you can
find out right now in this video right
here thanks for watching and I will see
you in the next one